Can you guys see him through recovery?
Yah I’ll take it. No, I can do it.
It's common practice for doctors to scrub up
before performing surgery or delivering babies.
But this was not always the case.
In the mid-19th century, Dr. Ignaz
Semmelweis was the first to figure out
how to prevent doctors from spreading
a deadly infection to pregnant women.
In 1846, he was appointed as
an assistant in the maternity
ward of the renowned Vienna General Hospital.
While there, he noticed something peculiar.
The maternal mortality rate in the
ward run by doctors and medical
students was significantly higher
than in the ward run by midwives.
Between 1841 to 1846, 4 women out of
100 died in the clinic run by midwives.
Whereas the one handled by doctors and
medical students had a striking 10
women out of 100 lose their lives.
Why would mortality rates be so
different between the two wards?
Semmelweiss was baffled and wrote:
“Everything was in question;
everything seemed inexplicable;
everything was doubtful. Only the large number
of deaths was an unquestionable reality.”
Pregnant women assigned to
the ward with the doctors
begged to be transferred to the other ward.
They were so afraid they preferred
to give birth on the streets,
where they had a lower chance of
dying from the mysterious disease.
Semmelweiss vowed to get to the
bottom of what was going on.
Then, in March 1847, came a breakthrough.
His colleague Jakob Kolletschka had
performed an autopsy, and a student
accidentally pricked his finger with a scalpel.
He died from an infection similar
to the one that afflicted the women.
Semmelweis realized doctors started each day
performing autopsies on the women who had died
shortly after giving birth, and then, examined
pregnant women without washing their hands.
Whereas the midwives had
never handled dead bodies.
He hypothesized that the doctors were transferring
some kind of “cadaverous particles” from
the dead bodies to the pregnant women.
Doctors at the time didn’t know
that bacteria caused infections.
They believed diseases were caused by bad odors,
humidity, the stress of giving birth,
or some kind of imbalance in the body.
Bacterial infections entering
the reproductive tract can
cause severe complications during or after birth.
An infection known as puerperal fever or
childbed fever can lead to intense fevers,
foul-smelling discharge, and excruciating pain.
Death often occurred within days of giving birth.
Newborns could also contract
the infection and die.
So, Semmelweis ordered his medical staff to wash
their hands with a disinfectant chemically related
to chlorine to remove the smell of decaying
corpses…before attending to the pregnant women.
The mortality rate dropped immediately.
In 1848, the clinic run by doctors and medical
students fell to 1 death per 100 births,
which was slightly below the rate
of the clinic run by midwives.
When Semmelweis wrote to the heads
of several maternity clinics about
his discovery, you’d think they’d
be eager to embrace hand-washing.
But they refused.
The prominent American obstetrician
Charles Meigs famously said:
“Doctors are gentlemen, and
gentlemen’s hands are clean.”
Many doctors pushed back
against the suggestion that
they were to blame for their patients’ deaths.
It didn’t help that Semmelweis waited 13 years
before officially publishing his
findings, in which he lamented:
“...my teachings are either ignored or attacked.”
He continued to urge the medical
community to listen to him, writing:
“...this truth must be made
known to everyone concerned.”
His book was long and included heavily
convoluted passages that didn’t help his case.
Semmelweis was also difficult to deal with.
He’s been described as having “...a temper
like a rattlesnake and was outrageously
rude to anyone who questioned his
ideas,” said Dr. Irvine Loudon,
who was a medical historian and author
of "The Tragedy of Childbed Fever."
Not long after Semmelweis made his discovery,
the head of the obstetrics department at Vienna
General Hospital refused to renew his contract,
another example of the resistance to his ideas.
He abruptly left Vienna to
return home to Budapest,
where he worked at a hospital and
continued to advocate for hand washing.
Despite virtually eliminating maternal
mortality at the hospital in Budapest,
his ideas were still rejected.
The professor of obstetrics at the
University of Pest, Ede Flórián Birly,
maintained his belief that childbed fever
was caused by uncleanliness of the bowel.
When Birly passed, Semmelweis
took over his position at the
university and grew increasingly erratic.
He wrote angry letters to his critics,
calling them “irresponsible murderers.”
He became severely depressed and began
drinking heavily and spending more time
away from his wife and five children
and in the company of prostitutes.
The University fired him for
his inappropriate behavior.
It’s believed he may have
developed early-onset dementia.
Or perhaps, the criticism of his life’s work
caused him to suffer a mental breakdown.
In 1865, Austrian physician Ferdinand Ritter
von Hebra lured him to a mental asylum in
Vienna under the premise of showing Semmelweis the
facilities. Landes-Irren-Anstalt in Lazarettgasse
When Semmelweis realized he was actually being
admitted as a patient, he tried to leave.
That’s when several guards beat him up, put him
in a straitjacket, and threw him into a cell.
He died two weeks later at the age of 47.
Very few people attended his funeral.
His autopsy revealed he died
from blood poisoning from a
wound on his hand that he could
have sustained from the beating.
Ironically, the man who spent
his life fighting against the
spread of infections died from an infection.
Two years after his death, French microbiologist
Louis Pasteur made a monumental discovery.
Pasteur realized that bacteria were spoiling wine.
And that these microorganisms were not
only responsible for spoiling food and
drink but also for spreading infectious diseases.
Unlike Pasteur, Semmelweis had not taken the
time to examine particles under a microscope.
Had he been a more diligent scientist,
If he had, he would have seen that they
were teeming with bacteria, which could have
made his case for handwashing more convincing.
Pasteur’s work inspired Scottish surgeon Sir
Joseph Lister to introduce
the concept of antisepsis,
the practice of using chemical agents to
prevent the growth of bacteria on living tissue.
Listerine is named after Dr. Lister.
By this point, Semmelweis was all but
forgotten; Lister had never even heard of him!
Hand washing and sterilizing medical instruments
finally started to become standard practice in the
1860s, twenty years after Semmelweis warned
doctors about the importance of hygiene.
Had his sanitation techniques
been implemented earlier,
there’s no telling how many
lives would have been saved.
Given that the death rate for women who
gave birth in hospitals was as high as
20% in some instances, it could have been
in the hundreds of thousands or even more.
It was only decades later that Semmelweis
finally started to gain recognition,
as the medical community became more
receptive of the germ theory of disease.
He’s now widely known as the “savior of mothers”.
Semmelweis once said:
“When I look back upon the past, I can
only dispel the sadness which falls upon
me by gazing into that happy future
when the infection will be banished.”
Sadly, he never lived to see that day.
As we've seen with Semmelweis's work,
the power of scientific thinking can
lead to life-saving advancements.
If you’d like to sharpen your science,
technology, engineering, and math skills,
I recommend Brilliant.org, a website and app
where you can learn through physical insight.
My viewers especially love their Scientific
Thinking course, where you can, for example,
figure out how to make this bridge as rigid
as possible with as few beams as possible.
There's everything from computer science to
foundational and advanced math to data science.
Brilliant is great for both beginners and those
who want to improve on what they already know,
which is crucial to help you stay ahead
in today's competitive marketplace.
As you progress through their lessons, you
can dive deeper into more advanced topics.
I personally use Brilliant to
boost my analytical thinking
skills by going through their logic puzzles.
Brilliant supports you every
step of the way. If you’re stuck,
you can view the explanation
to see where you went wrong.
You can try out Brilliant for free
for 30 days by heading to the custom
link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up
with my link will get 20% off their
Premium subscription, which gives
you access to all the offerings.
Thanks for watching. I’m Cindy Pom.